hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast visualization software creates
results quicker and involves biologist
I'm Julia Roberts and i'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by kokor a world leader in the
development of bioinformatics software
click or began in 2007 as a
collaborative research project at Lund
University Sweden supported by
researchers at the Department of
Mathematics and clinical genetics in
order to address the vast amount of
high-dimensional data generated by
microarray gene expression experiments
it was recognized that an interactive
scientific software tools needed to
conceptualize the ideas evolving from
the research collaboration the clue
course software takes full advantage of
the most powerful pattern recognizers
that exists the human brain click or has
clients in more than 25 countries and
most are from the life science and
biotech industries for more information
please visit www and a box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can you can
enlarge slide window by clicking on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems viewing or
sharing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left I would now like to
introduce today's speakers call johann
iverson president of cukor and t waslley
retros and BTW HD professor and senior
consultant call johann iverson has more
than 20 years experience in the software
and telecommunication industries and
broad experience from international
business management and sales is one of
Clue course founders and has been the
company's president since 2007 he worked
at ericsson from nineteen ninety eight
to two thousand seven during that period
call Johann among other tasks built and
managed
the new product management unit at
ericsson mobile platforms in 2001 and
headed ericsson mobile platforms in
china from two thousand four to two
thousand six dr. Fleurette rose is a
professor and senior consultant at the
department of clinical genetics
university and regional laboratories at
Lund University an elected member of
several learning society associate
editor of genes chromosomes and cancer
he has published more than 100
scientific original research articles
and reviews in international journals
service as a review reviewer for several
national and international funding
agencies and is apart from Cukor also
co-founder of Campari ad I will now turn
it over to Karl Johan ireson for his
presentation okay thank you for being
production I will change here to my life
presentation and the hope you can hear
me in a good way
okay during the webinar we will present
how you can generate new scientific
ideas and also free up the x mark
acquittal one-fourth of the webinar will
be a live demonstration of ppl makes it
grow we will also share examples on how
to format explore if we use to apply if
you studied not difficult the overall
figures provide massive data analysis
the annual worldly department them this
is the commercial aspect of the
challenges that scientists and
researchers of faith I think it's fair
to assume that they're all in agreement
that amount of data to be analyzed is
flowing very far and improves dilution
or required to maximize outcomes of the
January to data data analysis is
currently a bottleneck in many
organizations to us at uber and thought
science it has been clear for several
years that we believe them to the ever
growing amount of data is not only for
the computers more haunted for new
houses all this is indeed needed but
it's not enough the speed world in
number analyst deposition compliance
missing by plantation or one part of the
solution but again more is required to
increase Delta resolve amount of data
and knowledge buried with invitees when
we need clients that commonly
communicate that a lack of finality
resources blocks knowledge of faith
developments are closed for this stuff
our peaceful resolution is to enable
data analysis closer to the data tool
that is to improve involve the
scientists and the researchers to design
a deformed experiment for study one
significant aspect in making this
possible is to provide a software tool
that for forest and easily enough to
non-expert users these leaves scientists
attitudes the broad range of thought and
data analysis only one over the time
this amplifier software program without
see
konica and without extensive
requirements for being the backlog
knowledge you finding or improved
results it involved and for our clients
tribal there are many sources that
points to the cooperation between group
and having to write some potential for
thin or significant problems or
fundamental asset to achieve new fine
except yourself to secure the
environment by scientists and better
manage data analysis will connect we are
using three key elements in the design
of people explore visualization is in
the center this is vishal and easy to
understand exactly used to be reinforces
the analysis it will also enable the use
of itself I don't recognize number of
human brain now clicking point uses say
as to make the program easy to be no
scripts and no requirements on writing
code is there the required functionality
is only a few mastic for with feet big
data analysis and exploration shall be
rewarding and available to scientists
the solution must be four people make
the floor is faster than all other
solution for advanced information the
sensing update instantly to the full
range of data set that's more to lot
this is also true to advance and
information which visualization such as
principal component analysis at this
point we were like modern anything at
this point we would like to make one
clear safe you should not mix up to 40
meters grower with your visualization
program which are very limited analysis
conducted the in solution normally only
help you to make nice pictures of what
you already know the to format this
board will insert empty to find what
you're looking for and drive your
research first this with tan feliz
annotation what could be more relevant
than to kill you [ __ ]
like them what we want but before the
demonstration I would like to share one
example informative case studies on mon
amour client and then also invites to us
directors wanna see the founders to
share the efficient and fine example on
how we have been using google next
exploded we stay pissed off with a case
study the Center for interdisciplinary
to cali gaas go with the scientists
think was created in 2009 by the
dragonmen winners of people and the
Kohler Company and alerts the center is
located in for the procurement group at
the lair part of the fashion thing
integrates the latest technologies in
mass spectrometry and collaborate with
the center's name is earthly these
groups sub is focused on four major
biological processes contributing to
Colorado City macrophage biology click
in metabolism or Terrell and modular and
calcification and the ability for words
such as high-speed clip their situation
is that they have a lack of one of our
tribe vivillon hello yes what's lie
would you like to be on now I'm only
seeing slide one big and you please move
it in the studio
so okay baby let's continue
the proteomics groups are fixed
ledbetter profession seeing integrates
the latest technology from mass
spectrometry and collaborate to the
Templars main research group these
groups studies focused on 49 year of
biological cells that respond to those
in co vascular disease macrophage
serology lipid metabolism arterial and
values and specifications and metabolic
before such as security of their
situation and pieces that have a lack of
anesthesia and the majority of their
staff our biologists and the main
charity to match the resurfacing the the
solution that the student was to
implement you for effective floor for
the holiday the outcome has been
successful and the deployment as
visibility build understanding of the
data for the relative as well as seeing
up the concert information with this
case study and several others including
more details on available as we sort of
form and now I will hand over the to a
theater it will share with you some of
it aspect and thank you call you one so
and one of the founders of clue core and
and I just wanted to share with you some
ideas we have in the beginning when we
started out to build this software and I
think it's fair to say that we wanted
this software to analyze large scale
data set to be easy and it should only
require basic knowledge so I'm a medical
doctor biologist and and time does not
permit me as a person or a leader of
research group to learn how to run
scripts or writes great so the absolute
requirement was that it should only
require basic knowledge we also wanted
to bring the data back to the biology
and allow them to be initial data
and exploration I think that's very
critical if you want to be a successful
project that the date is not shared
anything that the data is not separated
between biologists medical doctors or
for sinus medication should also
driveway activity and generate a new
hypothesis so it should be a highly
interactive software and it should of
course then also facilitate the
interaction with expert in their expert
i hereby petition and you know them to
focus on more advanced enough the free
up time so on this in the next slide
this is just an example that we used
early on in 2010 where the software
click the shutter was critical just to
see this resulted in a paper published
in pnas and what we did in this study
was like typically nixle we're actually
leukemic themselves and patients
directly with the gene expression
profiling by race and later on by RNA
sequencing and then we used the cooper
software and a feature that will be
shown later back on you whenever so that
we could you just look on subsets of
your data so in this case we only looked
for 12 surface markers that were
differentially expressed in the leukemic
stem cells we can then later on validate
that one of these receptacle in this
case I'll unwrap the skylab regulators
are themselves separate these two
gimmick sensors generate antibodies that
can then kill off the leukemic Delta
this is just one example where Cooper
has been very critical for for for
identifying a critical result in cancer
biology so we left the hand and with a
total to 2.1 million country thank you
to us this brings us now close to the
demonstration and and we will work with
a data from leukemia and we will
actually work with two different data
sets during the demonstration we will
generate
new have 150 by dinner caged in a new
statute and also find eliminating
variables for known annotation and of
course with Eliza yourself finally
really compare our findings it's public
information and also limit the
biological skills that we are threatened
by using sleep a pencil you understand
we're only showing a small part of
available functionality the first step
in data analysis is to import data and
we know that many users right over this
and wonder how do i import data and what
types of data can be 63 dormant explorer
use generic algorithm methods and you
just make any assumptions on the type of
data imported so forth to fix it for all
types of data and of various sizes
campuses examples of data are gene
expression and DNA methylation and
proteome and so on you can always use
delivered to for import of any type of
normalize data for source and data types
and instruments that are building now
our building was built cities boot
normally take the four month is very
good and also large database differences
500 samples and fifty thousand variables
for order can be focused and analyzed
with a normal computer so i will now
again try to set up my desktop here with
you and I look like that is working so I
hopefully in front of you you've been
out to chromic the floor with a data set
with 132 samples and I'm slowly rotating
the sample PDF lost with 100 130 to stir
and what we'll do first here is to start
with a date that experience
we will work to find structure and
information in this data together before
we do that yeah give you one hint on how
you interpret the tea table I will show
you more flow types later on but two
spheres is representing a sample of
patients in these things that are close
to each other have a similar expression
factor and please we're set of four from
each other are very different the data
is gene expression and under the patient
of children who have or suffering from
leukemia we don't see any stop group in
the club and the reason for that is that
have the most of the variables County
the 20 2350 process or contributing only
business to handle that with how to use
the variance cake drink which is a 15
very powerful functionality through
formative floor especially when it is
combined with visualization so this is
really one of the unique features that i
have talked about that you get the
instant visualization i can move the
slider slowly and you can see how the
data is changing you can see in the PGA
Tour how data is splitting into two do
this value here is called reaction spore
and it helps you to sign the death wish
annotation in a PDF of it shows you the
highest level of information that is
captured compared to land of late I am
somewhere around here Oh points43 you
can see that there is the maximum
here suffer and they tighten clearly
speaking to people to capture that
information i will create the new
annotation and give it a couple of
values i will follow up report and then
i will use my mouse still over here
which controls a lot of the actions in
the program make sure it isn't mouse be
there and then now i've created a new
annotation with the name new annotation
i changed us to explore and i have
started to work and give and deep down
into the structure of the state of it
and as you can see i may be used my can
fix with the mouth and the sliders or so
on and this is really how the program
works and how easy it is if I then would
like to have a few salute to the
viewport I can uncheck the yellow sample
group here and then i canna job to see
if i can find a good utilization I can
to make the nearest neighbors I will
take the little bit and you see there is
much much more stuff structure and this
data sets and you have to to show you I
think justifier and I circle handle data
I can bring back my yellow group and
this is how easily it is to work with
some selection now you have to salute
that we haven't just invented strange
things here and found a norm relevant
food how will be my ride hope you have
the samples colored iPhone into my
explorer annotation and in the second
window here to the left I will follow
the data I pour into an annotation for
leukemia society the classification of
the sample based on their other clinical
scientists started to shift positions of
did you study originally out of the time
and as you see the yellow group we
identified specific to the orange group
here which is the comm group and the
total market equal to the vector
analysis of the e to a PDF if so we have
gone to find all the relevant groups yes
here in a few minutes used in various
filtering reaction force and cd8 and
signal was a very new database this was
actually a very good way to get a
feeling for the the date of death if now
this wouldn't have been matching towards
my original hypothesis which we can say
leukemia subsides annotation of
represent I would have known that I
potentially have a batch problems that I
would need to take care of ok now we
like to restart the analysis and have a
different approach so you have to show
you that i will close down the data that
i will open it up again
so here we have it painted a sense of
self I will do a little bit different to
third so the purpose now my hypothesis
is that I would like to find the
discriminating team that can separate
the CL a male 1 group from the other so
I store with color in my data you have
to show you how easy it is to be
selective I would remove the tiara then
I need to set up my political thing and
since I'm going to look for one good the
PLM ll 1 and group compared to the
others it is two wheels here Connie and
I find that field defining the
statistics dialogue I select my
annotation i selected PLM one room and
then it's game so and then I can just
move the slider and concise and sort to
set a p-value castle to remove variables
but the purpose of the demonstration I
will change the heat map so that you can
see that there are more prototypes and I
with particle clustering on that one
including and calories according to this
I will also do one more change change
this is the data that is from posted but
i will late laters that I like to
compare religious anything in another
aspect I changed that identifies the
team symbol then there is very common
and problem that you need to solve there
are multiple folks s matching to that
kingdom so we need to collapse the data
so now I'm recalculating and for all
rule in the data each row in the
database level not much to more than one
process we collapsed on on using an
average method and we can also change to
give people here on the back
so we are done and now we shall have a
look on how many variables with abs and
we see that here in the value stabbed
and then I start to filter and you get
the interactivity again I thought to
remove gene and the deal really really
strong p value cutter and we can clearly
see that I'm separating out the blue
group as we were trying to do and hear
all the others and this list was an
update automatically and that is a list
of the genes that are currently taking
for analysis the one certainty on
templating PLA and a one-sample don't we
have it clear you see the p-value cut
off here is the corrected value the
force discovery rate you can also work
with full change so we are not only
interested in the political significance
at all so they suspect so let's add a
fortune 50 of two so now we have the
genes that are told to and this physical
castle under known the 15 and i will use
the pastor feel more so than I just
easily change my slider here get
something like that we get both up
regulated genes and down-regulated Lee
to capture this result I make a copy and
then a homily so these are the ones that
are separating the clm a group from the
earth and you get to fold the elements
or at least feel and you get the meter
information about how those done or
rather sophisticated and Dustin all be
safe we can of course export images you
can export videos when you're Tuesday
lost an hour of additional information
should have added here so that you can
clearly see the p-values you can add
their fall together rate and you have a
solo and you have that you take that
there sometimes we are safe at least in
everything stayed so now I would like to
move and to a tick and data fit and to
verify my word stance in that second
base of it and I can do that by
downloading for instance beta test on
gene expression Omega and I just have to
go here to buy download and see you
later then I add my obsession number in
this case I will ready know it but if
you don't know exactly what you're
looking for we like to browse all
available datasets you get quick links
here to the keel so now I know so now
that I get the question which
annotations are like i have downloaded
these data sets before so many
facilities place nobody's really big
forces when you do it the first time and
this is a difference leukemia data sets
with 190 sample them done by a different
food for generated by the frontal
research group it is include the one
annotation which is characteristic for
example there are classified into
different groups so we can color access
to them we also need to handle the fact
that identifies here for 404 ID web but
we would like to have a computable solar
system file and again a few mouse clicks
and we have the datasets prepared and
organized according to its being simple
if we have to look at this we can see
that the blue samples here which I was
here I'll for seeking out by
significantly and that was
you also saw in our other data that
after a little bit of things doing that
for the practical now let's see one of
these taking data that look if I use the
result for my first date of it and again
how difficult is that it's only must
stick to it so now i use the base of the
34 jeans for my first data access our 29
matches of those keys in this dataset
and what happens we stepped clearly the
t-state books clothes of those 34 jeans
for separating out these yellow samples
over here and they are the PLA ml 1 so
we generated a list of the best
discriminating g-force tal que no one
sample for the group in one date of
death the use of the list of
discriminating variables and visualize
how it within a few days off in a second
data system you have verified and
investor has a lot to significant we can
then further refine the analogous life
opening here with an open comparatively
you
here we do is we take you to take
Genesis so this is the list of of genes
that are passed by the Senate is and we
see the pair of one answer to fix
matches so now I effect if Ted be like
that we go back to my first paper there
for it like that a little bit definitely
what are we doing now now we are looking
for the genes that are discriminating
the TL ml1 good boom we have a good but
that also are classified as an IT and
then we have that result here again so
that is how easy it is to mystery and
was only the subset of your variables
and the rest with the dollars of
relevant context depending on your
research area what for a joint to see
what other has published sandstorm that
is what i plan to show you here a very
very quickly going to full time and
giving you feeling for the flexibility
of total romantic school and let's see
we can move back to the slide
when you'll see the short demo and we
like to we would like to show you how
you can implement within your own
organization the third example is
between academia the scope of analysis
within academia is normally very good
and those exploration and analysis we
find the lighter types of ships are very
well is the closing license in to see
give a soul igloo acted to the program
but with limited for these days I come
from many sources and normally not
specialist support the scientist needs
support from a program to be able to
import data and that is deeply handling
3 4 and the whistle is very flexible
email getting data into the difference
as I mentioned easy download of gene
expression formerly birth data and also
filled in the inset enrichment analysis
orphan make it very easy there is a
broad range of statistical tools I only
show you the children comparison a
fortune for there is no fleet and older
framework and with including back
selection and then you can export your
results both publications and with
rather than need the information to keep
track of on the world if you look at the
examples on the form industry then it's
more use for exploration and our focus
this generation compared to do in
statistical sense it normally to inform
a small Bank magicians or substitutions
of themselves the sciences physical test
that is also irrelevant for the data
import a specter fair is normally more
support and one very straightforward way
is to use prefer thursday night dead and
then we have a form of to death before
that we Gator so scientists can get data
from central storage as well as in a
conversation but then acted to public
data can be very valuable and for
sharing and keeping track of your work
official functionality for low points
that you freeze the state of the program
and then easily can do that exports and
so on are similar and easy to use as a
shady thanks for watching and we would
like to start to summarize the field or
method floor can bring to the
organization in short it enables glazing
analysis by maximizing Sciences
involvement and optimizing the user with
this thing that you'll perform at the
floor is that it is for everyone all
actions and selections are done we
checked with the gyro and among its
aboard explore to the analysis based on
visualization and it's much more
powerful than a traditional reporting to
the juicer is always in full control to
the instant visualization and also the
easy to use click and put it into the
program can be used for both experts
working with it every day and by using
google search fulfills many other top
which is possible tentative easy to
learn and easy to your mother then the
question is will it work in your
organization of course one proof point
is that the list of more than 300
publications at 340 for their will
publish scion clients and referring to
the use of performance but it's always
best star by yourself so we have a free
file we can download it at three perform
we will give you full support during the
trial and if you have any questions now
for later feel free to awesome I know
that they already have some questions
and let's see what what or host is going
to help us with here yes thank you both
for sure
information with us before we get
started on the question and answer
session i would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window will try
to get to as many questions as we can
and our first question is this clue car
omix explorer require any special
hardware oh it doesn't really fit we'll
run it on animax or any and
windows-based computer and it is very
resource efficient so you don't have to
have the toughest over retirement it
really works that well okay can 10 more
than one user in my organization use the
trial version absolutely the trial
version is free for download so if
you're five min organization may be
attributed doesn't no problem did you
work on RNA seek Tina absolutely there
is the direct import functionality for
so called Sam time so that you can
import it directly and it's normalize
and you are running analyzing your data
within me how can it be so fast there
are many reasons for that rom is that we
have a center of effort in writing
efficient code and selecting the
absolutes very clearly and I think also
it is best experience of a relative the
speed helps to verify them how often do
you release updates and add new
functionality yeah we normally do one
release every year then we are new
functionality
um I know it is possible to use crew car
omics software to screen your database
for genes grouped into known pathways
such as part of AG or protein synthesis
how do I do this ok that is the
typically world what we can use the
in-between set enrichment analysis work
them for which I didn't show you and
after download the program in science we
will assist you there there is a
ridiculous around this for how to
analyze both ways of preventing the
documentation for focus of people what
is used already by reproduction groups
to identify new potential targets in
human in fraternity yeah I don't know
that top of my head here please have a
look at all the references that we have
a free service or how about proteomic
data from Nash parametric analysis okay
excellent question again here thank you
all for the question sir and it works
perfectly when a proteomic data and we
have a lot of customers can do that i
mentioned the case study here from six
they are working with the mass defect
data so there are many other examples of
that soup if there are no more questions
I would like to once again thank call
Johan Iverson and dr. floor a toast for
their presentation do you have any final
comments for us today yes thank you very
much all of you for watching and we
understand that there has been a lot of
technical challenges and under some also
say that none of you
is there thank you very much so that
visualization is really going to self
you in your research and the best way is
the fryer and you will get the instant
visualization and support doing and
finding you will result with in your
hand getting in touch with a paper thank
you oh yes and or you're speaking for
both of you then I would also like to
thank our sponsor clue core for making
today's educational webcast possible
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through june first
2016 you'll receive an email from lab
roots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you before that announcement to your
colleagues to miss miss today's live
event okay next time goodbye